yet again we have been given a new look
at doctor strange and a multiverse of
madness so disney has released new high
resolution images these photos were
originally featured in the latest issue
of empire magazine in lower quality the
first showcases benedict cummin batches
doctor strange in his new outfit lit
from behind by candles could he be
looking at elizabeth olsen scarlet witch
she can be spotted in previous trailers
surrounded by similar looking candles
next is wong seen as people don't
normally sit casually with their hands
behind the back it would seem that
someone has a wizard tied up finally is
america chavez who will have her first
appearance in this adventure there's not
much to extrapolate from this image
besides that she's either running away
from or towards something maybe this is
the same street gargantos can be seen on
we also have a new promo image here of
scarlet witch in her new outfit and
another image of doctor strange and
america chavez which looks like they
could be inside of the sanctum of
sanctorum possibly this is after the
encounter with gagantos on the street
which we have seen in the trailers now
while these images don't give us too
much information it's still exciting to
see that the marketing for doctor
strange is starting to push with about
40 days into the film releases i'm sure
we'll get a lot more from the film in
the coming days the oscars are tomorrow
so possibly we'll get something from
then and there's also a rumor going
around that on the 6th of april the
tickets will go on sale for the film now
normally when the tickets go on sale
they've released a trailer with it so
they can build up hype and at the end of
the trailer they'll announce the tickets
and then people can go buy them so
possibly a final trailer could be
released or a special look trailer which
normally goes for about 60 seconds and
then after that when it's about a few
weeks or a couple weeks into the film
comes out then we'll start to see many
many tv spots from the upcoming film so
pretty exciting stuff guys and in the
next month or so we're gonna have a lot
of doctor strange too to cover so stay
tuned for that and also let me know what
you think of his images in the comment
section below if you haven't already
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys